playing KX100 my final score in Norway
was five and a half out of nine
I drew a couple low rate players drew a
couple high rated players
but the games were fun
yeah probably go for C4
this is some Theory I think
C6 I generally like to see
I get these structures a lot from London
they were black essentially tried to
play a slav
but it's a very pleasant structure for
white
Queen B3 is pretty much forced
maybe maybe Queen A5 is
what blocks considering
almost everyone takes on B3 okay
and the plan is to move back and then
get the B Pawn rolling
um
just wondering
do I have to play H3 I might have to
play H3 just ensuring that um the bishop
doesn't
get traded off my H5 is sometimes an
idea
so I'm going to go for this plan
and this is way more of a positional
game
I have the bishop pair I have a little
bit more space B7 is someone of a
long-term Target
if I just put the 9 A5
there's essentially two ideas for black
to hold on to the pawn
one is to put the Rook on A7 which is
kind of sad
another idea is to play bishop d8 and
Trade It Off
but if Bishop d8
and then there's ideas later
which maybe we'll eventually get to
wait 985 okay seven
have to watch out for E5
if I play King D2
that's the best way to do this
and then E4 happens
wait let's just play F3
E5 is not the other threat
and now King D2
so there's cases where after takes takes
then the long-term plan for whiteness to
put Rooks on B4 and B3
okay up about 50 seconds
Center is still okay
now it's two Bishops versus two knights
yeah
our Rooks are finely connected
and yeah the plan is um
at least you got one Rook attacking the
b-pawn
interesting so 96
play Rook A4
and The Rook yeah The Rook serves a nice
purpose attacking and defending
like D4 is really the only potential
weak spot but it's very easy to defend
not so easy for black to attack multiple
times
if the Rooks double up there's not
really a infiltration Square
I just want to put both Rooks on the B
file
and then Rook B8 I take on A6 if Rook
here I played Bishop D6
so there could already be some issues
for that
um
I had a four
I don't think I need to worry about
I have a G4
I just plundered
black had Knight C5 for a moment there
and my tongue was overworked
net blocks and like serious Time Brush
right now
um F5
yeah this looks really nice
wow
F6
where's my funny mate
oh it's such a funny position
I need the bishop
wait
you play G5
yeah I guess G5
unlocks like completely paralyzed
this Knight has no legal moves both
Knights have no legal moves oh it's so
funny neither does a king
wait boxing complete suzvon
always play Bishop F1
no none of Black's pieces could move
there now except the king
check
mate
oh what a funny position
I thought like okay a lot of things are
winning but I didn't realize black
like literally can't move anything
I could have taken two
like every every move loses something I
was very satisfying
it's so weird like especially in the
position
we traded Queens in two minor pieces
and this is a position where
both the blocks Knights are in Black's
own territory and neither Knight has any
legal moves that's super rare
but it was basically like a checker
setup
man
yeah that might have to be a standalone
like YouTube video
foreign